hello good evening my name is Deputy ol
and I'm with the Sheriff's Office this
is being recorded do you have your
license registration and insurance with
you I do um I'm going to have to turn
off my car and open the glove box
totally okay any weapons in the vehicle
I need to know about yeah was it was it
because I turned before um the person
walked over not here to talk to you
about that the issue is you turned into
the wrong lane at the intersection there
you turn into the nearest Lane second
lane yep you got to go to the nearest
Lane always had intersection okay I'm so
sorry okay okay uh are you guys going
here is this where you're what this get
to talk Bell we so why'd you pull in
here yes no why did you pull in here oh
oh well I don't know it was the first
place for need to turn over so which way
are you supposed to pull over when the
lights I'm going to pull towards um Taco
Bell but I because okay sorry that's not
my question when which direction you're
supposed to pull when they're red and
blue lights to the right so sorry and
you went I don't pulled over after well
that's good I suppose no yeah sorry I'm
soor okay um yeah
um yeah it's just in here
somewhere and I'm sure he wants a case
I'm so
sorry this and
then here you
go is your first name do you have two
first names or two middle names I have
two middle names two is my two middle
name Mia have you had anything to drink
tonight no when was the last time you
consumed
alcohol well it's about an hour ago but
I took a seler okay well that that beer
seler lior much okay so did you stop
drinking about an hour ago basically an
hour ago yes okay how much have you had
to drink throughout the evening just two
two celsor two selsors yes is it more
than here's a deal if you're honest with
me helps me do my job better shot and
One S so I'm that two that's two drinks
yeah one shot drink was this was the
shot a single or a double single okay
yes do you feel like you're okay to
drive yes 100% I would never drive under
the influence well I get a little
worried when people are driving after
they've had two drinks that's it's not
good yes but I wait like over an hour
before I drive and then I eat food too
food has nothing to do with it do you
know you need to wait about 2 hours per
drink before you can drive oh okay
so you waited about 30 minutes per drink
in here's the deal in this situation I'd
ask if you'd be willing to do some
voluntary field sobriety tests is that
okay yes okay hop on out for me we can
get we can do that right here let me
turn off my lights so they're not
flashing hop on out for me yeah so I am
in my swimsuit because we in the hot tub
okay do you have pants on yeah uh no I
don't does your does your coat cover you
would you like me to put my pants on if
you have on I I understand if you if you
have pants i' put some pants on on it's
a little
chilly did you bring pants with you yeah
yeah here's light oh yeah put some pants
on it's not warm out here all right yeah
that's totally okay I'm so sorry about
the lane part well okay I'm I can
forgive you for that I just want to make
sure you're driving
safely you got hot tub at your place is
that what you're saying yep okay and
then you need some Taco Bell I got you
just getting before we go like sleep but
we are completely so okay let me turn
these off so they're not in your face
yeah totally
okay just stand right there by your
bumper I'm meet you over
there all right
Mia these tests are voluntary I'm not
meaning to shine that in your face no
test your voluntary they can be stopped
at any time yes uh first thing I'd ask
you do you have anything to keep you
from walking or
balancing um no do you have any injuries
one leg shorter than the other nothing
like that okay are you on any
medications that you should be driving
with no any marijuana no any other drugs
you're not supposed to be taking no okay
just to two one shot and one CA from
over an hour ago totally understand so
can you stand with your feet just like
there hands right at your side can you
see the tip my pen right here yep do you
wear contact lenses or glasses okay no
do you wear contact lenses or glasses oh
I don't I don't okay follow the tip of
the pen where my fingers move and follow
with your eyes and don't move your head
does that make sense
okay
if you need to Blink feel free to Blink
as much as you need can I blink yeah
yeah that was a no you're doing just
fine my first time doing I'm so sorry
okay keep your hands at your side for me
yeah and there you go you're doing just
fine try to keep your I right hear my
fingers
moving fall not my light the pen right
here okay okay sorry I'm scared no
you're doing just fine I'm just trying
to remind you some people I'm scared I'm
so sorry
okay
this time we're going to go
up sry no you're doing just fine
okay okay is this the amount of alcohol
you consume tonight is this a large
amount of alcohol for you no compared to
what you normally drink no okay like I
do two and that's two and that's pretty
much I don't typically like to get
completely Tipsy or drunk okay okay let
me uh let's do this let's stand up here
where it's a little
flatter uh let's just take a couple step
right here where my flashlight at can
you stand right there where my
flashlights at the c y yep not right
here and then turn him back around and
face me right downhill this is about the
flattest spot we got here okay and then
just kind of put my foot in front of it
or let me give you some instructions
first okay so what I'd like you to do is
imagine a straight line out in front of
you towards my uh police car what I'd
like you to do on that straight line put
your left foot on that line and put your
right foot in front touching your heel
to your toe all the way to the car no
just the what do what I'm telling you
right now put your right foot in front
and stay there oh okay can you keep your
hands at your side for me now I want you
to stay in this position until I tell
you to start does that make sense okay
when I tell you to begin what I'd like
you to do is take nine Heel To Toe steps
down your line nine okay no don't start
yet don't start yet when I tell you to
begin it's going to be nine heel toe
steps heel touching your toe each step
look at your toes count out loud with
your hands at your side it's going to
look just like this okay one 2 3 I took
three I ran out of room you're going to
take nine does that make sense n on the
ninth step leave that front foot planted
like mine is step out with your back
foot take a series of small steps turn
around that front foot and nine more
back the way you came okay hands your
side one 2 3 I took three how many are
you going to take um nine down nine down
down put around side by side and then
turn around and you're going to take
nine steps back okay do you have any
questions before you get started no okay
nine down then step turn as I turn
around yep and then nine more back okay
okay go and begin whenever you're ready
okay you want me to count out loud I do
okay 1 testing
2 4 5
8 10
out
one step call 13 I'm out
testing okay took 10 down and 10 back
okay for this next one I don't care if
you're standing this way or you're
standing sideways wherever you feel the
most balanced side to side you try turn
to 90° try facing just straight downhill
does that feel better this is probably
straight downhill if you face towards me
this way just walking P nope you're just
going to balance right there how does
that feel you stable yeah okay so for
this I'm gooded but that and it's cold
I'm glad you put on some pants it's just
my leg shaking let me my radio person is
trying to get a hold of me just stay
right here for one
second step up all 13 I'm code for
testing all right man sorry they were
yelling in my ear is this like a
protocol or yep any when after you've
had alcohol to drink and you've been
driving this is the test I have to make
sure you're okay yes okay over an hour
ago yep okay so face this way and we can
whichever way you feel the most stable
totally up to you so what I'd like you
to do stay in this position again don't
start until I tell you to yes when I
tell you to begin what i' like you to do
either foot I don't care whichever one
you feel most comfortable with pick up
your foot your toe is going to be about
6 in off the ground your leg's going to
be straight and your hands are going to
be at your side okay look at your toe
and count out loud 1,1 1,2 13 and so on
until I tell you to stop okay okay toe
pointed so your foot's parallel straight
leg arms are at your side looking at
your toe count Out Loud by 1000s do you
have any questions no once you start the
test don't stop okay I'm just a little
bit shaky I'll give you credit for being
sh with the I'm just like like in I'm a
little shaky too cuz it's cold so and
it's cold go ahead and begin whenever
the hot tub gotcha yeah go and begin
whenever you're ready all right I'm
ready 1,000 2,000 3,000 4,000 5,000
6,000 7,000 8,000 9,000 10,000
11,000
12,000 13,000
14,000
15,000 16,000
17,000
18,000
19,000 20,000
21,000
22,000 okay go ahead and stop uh so last
test is a preliminary breath test it's
not in Li of the evidentiary test this
is a lot like blowing up a balloon okay
do you know how to blow up a balloon no
yeah I do you blow we've all blown up
balloon so pretty simple big breath in
lips tightly around the
straw blow out for about 2 or 3 seconds
okay in trouble could it's been an hour
since I last so what this does it it
basically tells me that you're being
honest with me and everything's happened
like you said it has this will just tell
me how much you had to drink if you've
had okay if you waited an hour and
you're under the legal limit that's fine
one shot and the 5% self it okay yeah I
just want to get in trouble I I to well
I don't want people get in trouble
either okay big breath in whenever
you're ready go ahead blow blow blow
blow blow keep blow keep going keep
going keep going keep going stop okay so
how old are you I'm 21 you're 21 do you
know the legal limit for someone who's
21 years old um I think it's
007 well close it's 008 do you think
you'd be over or under 08 I should be
like under you think you're under okay
and as soon as this clicks over I'm
going to show you the result and we'll
know okay my concern is I can smell the
odor intoxicants coming off your breath
so it's obvious you've been drinking
yeah that's normal the the problem is so
here's the that says you're a 102 so 08
is the legal limit for someone your age
okay so the problem is you are under
arrest right now for DUI so I need you
turn around put your hands behind your
back and I'm going to tell you
everything we're doing along the way
okay so nothing's a
surprise you are under arrest right now
you do have the right to remain silent
anything you say can be held against you
in the court of law you have the right
to the presence of an attorney you
cannot afford an attorney one will be
appointed you PR questioning if you so
desire you can decide any time to
exercise these rights not make any
statements or answer any question
do you understand the rights I've read
to
you and we are still recording I saw you
noding your head up and down and you
said mm is that a yes or a no yes okay
I'm just making double
sure well I'm glad nothing bad happened
like you didn't get in a wreck or that's
happened before too let's do this well I
don't think I'm drunk with the issue but
well here's the problem you're over the
legal limit we make mistakes driving all
the time okay I'm glad the mistake
wasn't the pedest in that was in the
crosswalk yeah um let's see uh anything
CR you just put your pants on so I'm
assuming you don't have any firearms in
your waistline or anything like that no
okay let's go over here to my my patrol
car we have some paperwork we're going
to do we're going to get your car taken
care of we're going to make sure your
passenger's got a away home let's go
over here to the other side of my patrol
car so step to Paul 13 one in custody
DOI uh face the vehicle for
me what's going to happen face the
vehicle separate your feet I got make
sure you just don't have anything in
your coat pocket here yeah there's
nothing in myet I got to double check I
get in trouble if I don't okay okay have
a seat in the car here I'm going to tell
you what's going to happen if you sit
with your bottom in there it should be
nice and warm careful okay so has your
passenger had as much to drink as you I
think she had the same amount same
amount okay do you have a silver friend
that could come pick up the car step to
Paul 13 one in custody DUI do you have a
sober roommate that could come I
literally
um can I leave your car with your
passenger is she okay to make sure your
car gets home and a sober driver at
everything I would PR I would prefer to
drive I mean not drive um I would prefer
you didn't drive I would prefer my
roommate to drive then right I I don't
want her to drive but can she get a hold
of your roommate and everything for you
yes if I uh give her my phone which is
somewhere in the front seat can we give
her the phone number for your roommate
yes because I you probably I'm going to
get you phone phone for you yeah I want
to make sure you have your phone you
need it more than her yeah okay anything
else out of the car that you need can I
give her the keys of the car is what I'm
asking sure okay um what's going to
happen to we so we have to go to pulman
do some
paperwork okay uh we might go up to the
WSU station cuz it's a little closer um
either way uh we're going to go do that
and have you ever been arrested for dii
before no just I'm going to explain to
you the whole Pro nothing's going to be
surprised I'm going to tell it to you
before before it happens be on my record
well right now you've just been arrested
you haven't been charged and you haven't
been convicted okay but I'm going to
explain to you every step of the way
what we're doing so let's figure out
what we're going to do with your car and
we'll get that situated then we'll get
on to the next step and I'll tell you
what's